vowels
we use them every day but how much do we
really know about them
in the english language we have five
specific vowel letters each with its own
unique personality
first off on this linguistic a-list is
well it's a about as popular and
versatile a letter as you can get a
balances representing an impressive
seven different vowel sounds with the
glitz and the glamour that comes from
being the english language's very first
letter a is literally the alpha of our
entire alphabet it's the highest grade a
teacher can give you for your work we
have a-list celebrities and many of us
grew up watching the a-team save the day
on a regular basis some scientists
believe that a has an entrenched
motivating impact on us and can improve
performance at work or creatively
a is quite playful it features in a lot
of words that are just well fun to say
like llama aardvark handbags balaclava
madagascar jazz hands to name a few and
a isn't too interested in numbers either
if you spelt out every number from one
upwards you wouldn't be using an a until
you got all the way up to 1 000.
e in contrast is much more grounded it's
the only vowel in our most used word the
and it's also the most used letter in
our entire alphabet appearing in 11 of
all the words we use it's the second
most likely key to break on your
keyboard from overuse
e is essential for storytelling it
allows us to write in the past tense
when e is left to its own devices it
takes a deep interest in the natural
world endlessly green elements stems
trees weeds levies etc
i
is very concerned with its appearance it
was the first letter to receive a dot
when in its lower case form and it's the
only letter that is always capitalized
when on its own it's also the first word
in the shortest complete sentence in the
english language i am it's great for
active verbs and when on its own it
appears in a host of words related to
excess and desire without it you could
have kissing or drinking or hitting or
spilling
or hardly any illicit thrills at all
out of all the symbols we use for vowels
o is the one that appears the most in
other languages even ones that developed
completely independently of each other
the shape of the letter o mirrors the
shape of your mouth as you make the
sound and it's thought that's why it
appears in so many different languages
this constant circular shape with no
beginning or end offers some of our most
mysterious words things like the moon
spooky howls grottos horror ghosts
groans moans and bones too
you is much more scientific and partly
due to its lateness in the alphabet
always has one eye on the future it's an
abbreviation for university for uranium
and is linked to submarines
it provides us with some pleasant words
but also some of our most unpleasant
ones
you also works well with other letters
it can be completely silent when it
wants to be and it can be rare to get
three vowels together in a row but when
it happens in most instances you is in
there holding it all together
so there you have it the english
language is vowels essential to everyday
life each one packed full of personality
you'd best learn to live with them
because you can't speak without them
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video